merci philippe Dominati de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de Paris à
parenté au groupe les républicains et on
va évidemment revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé cette dernière heure et c'est nuit
d'émeutes consécutives et cette nuit qui
a été plus calme est-ce qu'on va vers un
retour de la paix oui je pense qu'on va
avoir un retour d'une vie normale il y a
les départs en vacances il y a les
enfants qui sont ne sont plus scolarisés
et puis il y a les magasins qui ne sont
plus à Challans aussi donc on ne peut
plus les billets c'est ça que pour vous
qui explique le fait que cette nuit
était plus calme oui en partie comme
tout mouvement toute crise il y a un
moment donné où ça redescend mais pour
autant cette crise existe c'est pas le
dispositif mis en place par le ministère
de l'Intérieur il y avait encore 45000
forces de l'ordre sur le terrain à
chaque fois on annonce un dispositif
important et ça n'empêche rien donc il y
a un problème il y a un problème soit de
gouvernance des forces de l'ordre soit
un problème de périmètre mais en tout
cas il y a d'un côté un drame et de
l'autre côté l'exploitation de
l'événement et c'est ce qui se passe en
réalité à chaque fois qu'il y a un
événement d'une nature
qui est sensible pour l'opinion publique
qui a l'exploitation l'exploitation
souvent c'est l'occasion de troubles de
pillage de désordre on va payer
sur l'exploitation politique
si vous promenez dans Paris vous voyez
bien que c'est l'image du pays qui est
totalement atteinte on sait très bien
que les touristes repartent il y a des
pays qui ont annoncé qu'il ne fallait
pas aller en France
on en a parlé à l'ONU donc en réalité
tout ça est désagréable parce que il y a
chaque mois tous les deux mois tous les
trois mois d'une manière répétitive et
exactement les mêmes problèmes et les
mêmes incidents on va revenir sur sur la
politique mais est-ce que l'exécutif a
bien géré est-ce qu'elle a eu raison de
ne pas déclencher l'état d'urgence ces
derniers jours je trouve que l'état
d'urgence c'était excessif comme mesure
et on ne peut pas passer ce temps au nom
du principe de précaution à interdire
tout je trouve que ces derniers temps je
m'y suis élevé les préfets agissaient
d'une manière trop rapide pour interdire
par exemple un certain nombre de
manifestations dès qu'on dit il y a un
problème on interdit il faut revenir je
dirais des réflexes normaux dans notre
pays autre il n'y a plus d'autorité et
c'est ce qui se passe sur les élus
locaux on s'aperçoit qu'à force
d'affaiblir l'autorité des maires
notamment ce qui s'est fait quand même
depuis six ans de la part du
gouvernement une vision technocratique
de la société et bien on désacralise les
responsables qui entretiennent le
dialogue avec les populations et
pourquoi on est obligé d'interdire parce
qu'il y a un problème de gestion une
incapacité de gestion
vous avez vu comme moi que l'emploi des
forces de l'ordre contrairement à ce que
dit Monsieur Bardella il y a largement
ce qu'il faut on est le pays où on a le
plus de force de l'ordre par million
d'habitants donc ce n'est pas le
problème c'est le problème d'emploi vous
avez vu comme moi bien souvent des
manifestations où vous avez plus
d'agents de l'État pour assurer pour
assurer la sécurité que de manifestants
donc c'est un problème d'emploi et
d'encadrement
plus la police aujourd'hui c'est la
police qui fait peur au pouvoir est-ce
que vous partagez ça non bien sûr que
non je partage pas du tout ce genre de
propos mais ce qu'il y a de vrai c'est
que c'est un ministère où les syndicats
ont pris une position trop importante et
parfois scandaleuse lorsque je vois le
communiqué du syndicat Alliance qui se
dit républicain or ce n'est pas la
première fois on peut se demander si
effectivement dans la police nationale
il y a pas des syndicats qui jouent avec
le feu juste pour que tout le monde
comprenne bien l'alliance c'est l'une sa
police qui se disent en guerre contre
les nuisibles
oui et qui menace le gouvernement au nom
soit disant d'une
police républicaine or il faut bien voir
que le Parlement en 2017 aligné l'usage
de l'arme des policiers parce qu'ils
sont dans des zones sensibles et très
dangereuses sur l'usage fait par la
gendarmerie depuis l'an dernier par
exemple 13 morts dont 7 passagers des
véhicules
7 passagers c'est pas le conducteur dans
la gendarmerie zéro l'année précédente
10 dans la police deux dans la
gendarmerie pendant ce temps-là les
gendarmes sont formés à 92% et les
policiers sont très très mal formés à
Paris dans le périmètre de la préfecture
de police les séances de tir
obligatoires sont inférieures à 20% or
lorsqu'on a fait la forme cette loi
on a baissé la formation monsieur
Cazeneuve a ramené la formation qui
était de 12 mois à 10 mois et Monsieur
Castaner l'a ramené de 10 mois à huit
mois la formation et c'est Monsieur
Darmanin qui a aujourd'hui essaye de
rattraper les erreurs de chez
prédécesseur on leur reportant à 12 mois
mais donc les agents ne sont pas
responsables de se dysfonctionnement
qu'il y a entre le manque de formation
et en plus il y a pas de sanctions pas
de sanction si on ne fait pas les
sciences de formation ce qui se passe
pratiquement je vous ai donné un taux de
20%, il est excessif la préfecture de
police sur la zone Paris mais ce qu'il
faut la revoir cette cote 2017 Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il dit c'est une loi permis de
tuer c'est la loi qui définit les règles
de tir des policiers les conditions dans
lesquelles ils peuvent tirer notamment
est-ce qu'il faut la revoir je pense en
tout cas qu'il faut que l'encadrement
reprenne les choses en main et qu'il y
ait une vraie formation et que ce ne
soit pas les instructions syndicales
avec les excès qu'il y a de bien souvent
dans les instructions de ce type qui
donne une ligne de conduite aux
policiers mais il faut pas modifier cet
article
c'est une fonction très difficile où on
voit que les excès en milieu urbain sont
de plus en plus nombreux mais ce qu'il y
a de vrai c'est qu'il faut que il y ait
un une déontologie elle mode d'emploi
qui soit encadré ce qui n'est pas le cas
dans la police nationale
ontologie mais malheureusement je dirais
la formation avant lorsque vous aviez un
contrôle par exemple les policiers
mettaient la main sur l'arme ça
suffisait bien souvent parfois ça ne
suffisait pas donc on a aligné à la
demande déjà
des syndicats qui étaient allés voir le
président de la République le statut sur
les gendarmes les gendarmes sont des
militaires et les militaires ont une
formation je dirais plus plus forte dans
l'usage des arbres deuxièmement en
Île-de-France nous avons tous les jeunes
qui sortent des écoles avec une absence
je dirais de métier avec une crainte
avec un certain nombre de choses et ils
ne sont pas encadrés par les ceux qui
ont le plus d'expérience la plupart du
temps tout ça il faut le revoir il faut
améliorer le mécanisme je pense que la
mesure qui consiste à revenir à la
formation initiale avant l'abandon qui
avait été fait par Monsieur Cazeneuve
c'est une bonne mesure et peut-être
qu'il y aura des bons effets j'espère
dans peu de temps on va parler de ce qui
a marqué ce week-end c'est évidemment
cette attaque au domicile du maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses à Vincent Jean Brun le
porte-parole des républicains est-ce que
vous diriez malheureusement qu'un
nouveau cap a été franchi encore oui
bien sûr et on entend toujours le même
discours c'est-à-dire il y a même pas un
mois à Matignon était reçu un maire
démissionnaire en disant c'est la
dernière fois vous allez voir et cetera
et on voit jamais rien bien sûr
suffisamment protégé par l'État les mers
aujourd'hui c'est pas une question de
projection c'est une question d'autorité
je dirais l'autorité le respect ça se
décrète pas c'est pas parce que vous
allez mettre je dirais des
symboles pour la protection en ce qui
compte c'est les berges jusqu'à présent
avaient une autorité naturelle dans leur
commune mais lorsque on attaque cette
autorité par je dirais des décrets en
permanence lorsque dans les préfectures
moi j'ai eu un maire vendredi au
téléphone d'une petite commune 120
habitants il dit de toute façon à la
préfecture on nous écoute
on nous écoute plus on ne cherche plus à
rien c'est ça le désarroi des mers et
lorsque ils ne sont plus la courroie de
transmission suffisamment efficace
vis-à-vis de l'État vis-à-vis des
administrations lorsqu'ils ne sont plus
respectés par l'administration centrale
effectivement on a miné leur autorité ça
fait des années que ça dure ça fait des
années qu'au Sénat on le dit et ça ne
change pas il faut croire
les mesures prises par le gouvernement
proximité après la mort du maire de
signe après la mort du après la
démission pardon du maire de
Saint-Brévin il y a eu des annonces qui
ont été faites par le gouvernement
[Musique]
pour pouvoir écouter ses mères
dans les faits dans les faits quotidiens
on voit bien que le gouvernement n'a
plus l'habitude de travailler une mesure
vendredi soir pour des raisons de
sécurité on bloque tous les réseaux de
transport à 21h et on recommence le
lendemain bon on a demandé la vie à
quelqu'un
la personne qui sort de son travail pour
rejoindre son domicile à 25 km qui se
trouve prisonnière dans la dans la ville
moyenne ou à Paris en Île-de-France
comment elle fait on a demandé la vie au
maire
à qui on a demandé la vie non les
transports je dirais toutes les mesures
de la vie quotidienne sont gérés
théoriquement par l'État et bien souvent
avec le principe de précaution
ce qui se passe du côté de Paris on
retrouve Jacques paquet le directeur de
la rédaction du journal du Grand Paris
bonjour Jacques merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous
jetez nous parler d'un autre sujet on va
parler de Paris on va parler de
l'opinion des Parisiens sur leur ville
absolument bonjour monsieur le sénateur
un sondage de d'opinion noué pour nos
confrères du Parisien et paru récemment
deux sujets sur lesquels je voulais vous
faire réagir monsieur Dominati la
propreté c'est pas une surprise 71% des
Parisiens estiment que ne pas être
satisfait par l'état de
propreté comment vous feriez mieux
monsieur Dominati comment vous analysez
cette cette situation récurrente
écoutez comment je ferais mieux d'abord
lorsque j'étais dans la majorité au
conseil municipal de Paris il y a de
nombreuses années on faisait mieux je
pense que Paris n'était pas critiqué sur
ce critère là et la municipalité n'est
pas critiquée sur ce critère là d'abord
on mettait des moyens deuxièmement on
mettait la concurrence c'est-à-dire que
Bertrand Delanoë il faut bien voir que
ce sont des sujets qui se font sur le
long terme et Madame Hidalgo ne fait
qu'appliquer la politique qui a été mise
en place par Bertrand Delanoë on a voulu
municipaliser ce service avec des taux
d'absentéisme relativement importants et
des moyens plus faibles donc ça coûte
plus cher et ça fonctionne moins bien
voilà ce qui se passe essentiellement
sur la propreté mais s'il n'y avait que
la propreté qui ne fonctionnait pas à
Paris à la limite ça serait quelque
chose qui pourrait peut-être se résoudre
pareil une ville qui a vu un endettement
colossal se crée en quelques mandatures
a vu un nombre de fonctionnaires
performant assez important aussi en
plusieurs mandatures et puis avec une
politique de la ville incohérente parce
qu'elle doit faire face la majorité
municipale à la gestion de ses alliés et
les aliens sont pas d'accord dans cette
majorité municipale sur un certain
nombre de sujets concernant la ville
justement deuxième
ce sondage
on tend des conditions de circulation ça
aussi on le sait mais 41% estiment qu'il
faut poursuivre la politique de
réduction de la voiture qu'en
pensez-vous monsieur Dominati est-ce que
vous aussi vous pensez qu'il faut
poursuivre la réduction de la place de
la voiture je pense notamment à la zone
à faible trafic ou un trafic limité dans
Paris centre ou à la sanctuarisation
d'une voie dédiée sur le périphérique
écoutez moi j'ai été longtemps un élu du
centre de Paris et cette zone du centre
de Paris d'abord ce sont des élus de
droite qui ont fait le quartier
Montorgueil et toute cette
piétonnisation d'une grande partie du
deuxième et du premier arrondissement
donc je dirais je connais un petit peu
le sujet même s'il n'est pas
nécessairement d'actualité on en parle
souvent la ville de Paris n'a pas voulu
faire comme à Londres un système de
péage et la municipalité considère que
on n'a pas à réguler la voiture par un
coût financier qui était le pH dans le
centre de la ville on parle très souvent
du centre et des arrondissements
périphériques comme le huitième
arrondissement par exemple et donc ça a
été un débat récurrent Conseil de Paris
ce qui a de certains c'est que la
voiture doit prendre une place dans une
capitale mais une juste place et moi je
ne suis pas non plus pour le tout
voiture c'est vrai que technologiquement
des voitures de petites dimensions au
lieu de s'attaquer aux trottinettes
pourquoi madame Hidalgo n'a pas posé une
question sur les SUV c'était de la
démagogie en réalité entre un engin qui
était électrique et qui est très léger
mais qui concernait les jeunes et les
SUV où elle voulait redorer son image
dans les quartiers de l'Ouest parisien
on pourrait se poser des vraies
questions mais enfin je dis
qu'effectivement dans une ville moderne
la voiture doit avoir une place c'est
nécessaire pour l'activité c'est
nécessaire pour le tourisme c'est
nécessaire je dirais pour la vie
quotidienne mais une juste place
vont vous parler ce projet aussi pour
les municipales de 2026 absolument merci
Oriane et je voulais vous demander
monsieur Dominati vous êtes un élu
expérimenté si vous aviez des favoris
Emmanuel Grégoire est dans les starting
block ou même plus parce qu'il a créé
son parti on parle bon il y a Rachida
Dati chez les chez les LR on parle aussi
de Gabriel Attal de Clément Beaune on ne
manque pas de candidats putatif et si
vous avez des préférés
je ma préférence va vers l'alternance au
sein de cette municipalité qui arrive
pas à gérer cette grande ville cette
ville historique qui a effectivement
cette municipalité à son quatrième
mandat elle est à bout de souffle
maintenant cette alternance je trouve
qu'il faudrait qu'elle soit bénéfique
pour la ville et je pense qu'il faut
passer effectivement
à une nouvelle génération
concernant un projet pour la ville on ne
pourra pas faire un combat politique sur
des thèmes un peu anciens et donc je
pense qu'il y nécessité d'avoir de
nouveaux leaders à Paris c'est la
nouvelle génération non j'ai pas parlé
de non mais je Rachida Dati a essayé de
mener les élections municipales avec
brio dernières élections néanmoins la
droite a perdu depuis trois
arrondissements sur 9 et toutes les
circonscriptions législatives ça veut
dire que le camp auquel j'appartiens
n'arrive pas à convaincre actuellement
les Parisiens de faire l'alternance avec
nous donc on devra s'allier probablement
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je
prends du recul parce que j'ai
l'intention de me battre pour gagner les
prochaines élections municipales mais
dans une coalition qui sortent des
partis politiques parce que Rachida
Datti subit ainsi que les autres c'est
le républicain je dirais le désarroi que
subissent la républicains sur le plan
national en ne choisissant pas entre
plusieurs lignes politiques en tout cas
à Paris c'est une politique ne convient
pas donc elle peut pas être la candidate
de la droite à Paris
elle a le droit d'être candidate c'est
une que pour vous sauf qu'à un moment il
faut tenir compte des échecs et pas dire
j'ai échoué j'ai échoué j'ai échoué j'ai
échoué je suis toujours candidat il faut
proposer des solutions nouvelles c'est
tout Rachida Dati une combattante donc
c'est très bien elle exprime bien un
certain nombre d'idées c'est parfait
malheureusement on le voit aux élections
sénatoriales la majorité les
républicains ont explosé en deux tiers
1/3 pourquoi parce qu'il y a d'un côté
quelques arrondissements où on est bonne
corrigé dans l'Ouest parisien et on ne
parle pas au secteur sensible le sondage
dont vous parlez n'a aucun intérêt il a
aucun intérêt pourquoi parce que Paris
se gagne comme les élections américaines
c'est-à-dire il faut gagner dans trois
secteurs sensibles à Paris sur trois
quoi un secteur où il y a quatre
arrondissements et le 12e et le 14e
arrondissement c'est la majorité du
conseil municipal si on faisait un
sondage dans ces secteur là ça aurait un
intérêt maintenant sur les personnalités
nationales donc vous parlez j'ai
toujours connu des personnalités
nationales lorsqu'elles étaient en haut
de l'affiche comme dirait Aznavour être
candidat potentiel à la mairie de Paris
Villepin François Fillon
Édouard Philippe régulièrement
Jean-Louis Borloo on nous annonce la
venue de tel ou tel ténor pourquoi pas
tant mieux ça a été fait et cette ville
mérite effectivement des personnalités
de premier plan pour la gérer surtout
lorsqu'elle est mal gérée mais pour
autant il faut gagner dans ces
secteur-là et donc moi ce que j'attends
c'est que il s'engage si Monsieur Attal
veux venir il a qu'à le dire maintenant
mais faire parler la presse pendant des
mois et des mois et empêcher le débat
démocratique dans les quartiers ça ne me
convient pas
Yannick j'adore dans ma liste alors
là
ils sont au pouvoir depuis que quatre
mandatures et effectivement ils sont en
partie responsable des hésitations de la
majorité municipale mais effectivement
mais c'est un candidats qui rapidement
pour vous il faut un candidat d'alliance
entre la droite et les macronistes
je ne trouve qu'en perd du temps comme à
la dernière comme aux dernières
élections municipales et il faut un
projet si elle a mis une personne veut y
aller on reprend un certain nombre de
candidats mais on rajeuné les listes en
partie parce que je dirais il y a une
usure
un projet qui convient et si les
sincères vis-à-vis des Parisiens moi je
considère que Paris n'est pas
marche-pied pour réussir en politique
mais c'est un très bon candidat s'il
avait envie d'y aller
on a du
grand passif beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous Jacques évidemment à très vite
philippe Dominati vous allez quitter le
Sénat donc quelques semaines papa tout
de suite après quasiment 20 ans demanda
sur lesquels on va revenir avec
Alexandre Poussard qui nous rejoindre
[Musique]
Alex bonjour Philippe
dominatibles et on va voir avec vous les
temps forts des mandats sénateurs de
Philippe de vinati effectivement
philippe Dominati vous avez été sénateur
depuis 2004 vous avez occupé trois
mandats successifs à la haute assemblée
et on vous connaît d'abord comme le
sénateur spécialiste des moyens de la
police d'ailleurs vous en avez parlé en
début de cette interview vous étiez ces
dernières années et bien le rapporteur
du budget des forces de l'ordre au sein
de la commission des finances et vous
n'avez cessé de dénoncer le manque de
moyens matériels de nos forces de
l'ordre on va vous écouter c'était en
2018 le parc automobile est vieillissant
beaucoup trop moyen d'âge de 8 ans
lorsqu'on créé trois emplois dans la
Polynice on supprime une voiture donc il
faut que ça ne soit plus le cas si on
crée des emplois il faut qu'on fasse
j'ai un équipement autre volet de votre
action de sénateur le travail sur
l'évasion et l'optimisation fiscale vous
avez présidé en 2012 à la commission
d'enquête du Sénat sur l'évasion des
capitaux hors de France une évasion qui
représentait à l'époque selon votre par
rapport 40 milliards d'euros de pertes
pour l'État et ce chiffre 10 ans plus
tard et bien il a quasiment doublé et
puis politiquement on peut dire que vous
étiez un électron libre au sein de la
droite parisienne vous étiez membre de
l'UMP puis DLR jusqu'en 2017 et souvent
vous avez été élu sénateur et bien en
dissidence c'est à dire que vous
présentiez contre la liste de candidats
officiels investis par le parti
notamment le parti les républicains en
2017 et en 2017 et bien justement votre
liste de candidats avait fait mieux que
la liste officielle LR puisque vous
aviez remporté deux sièges de sénateurs
et ce soir de septembre soir de votre
réélection et bien vous n'étiez pas
tendre avec les républicains j'aperçois
qu'il y a eu une forte contestation à
Paris vis-à-vis de la direction
nationale du parti les républicains et
effectivement un fort désavu on a été
handicapé effectivement par la formation
politique qui s'est trompé dans le choix
et dans la composition on aurait pu
trouver une liste beaucoup plus
harmonieuse je l'avais proposé à ma
formation politique en temps et en heure
ils n'ont pas voulu ils ont voulu faire
d'autres calculs et bien les calculs
malheureusement ont mal tourné voilà
vous ne mâchez pas vos mots à l'époque
contre les républicains alors dans ce
paysage de la droite sénatoriale on peut
vous qualifier de Sarkozy si vous avez
souvent défendu l'ancien président de la
République y compris dans ses affaires
judiciaires récentes comment en 2021
quand Nicolas Sarkozy était condamné à
un an de prison ferme pour corruption
dans l'affaire dite Paul bismuth et bien
à l'époque vous dénonciez une justice
politique on va vous écouter le mur des
cons est encore une réalité c'est à dire
que on a du mal à comprendre parfois
quand est-ce qu'il y a la justice et
quand est-ce qu'il y a la justice
politique les exemples sont nombreux de
voir que des magistrats ont largement
dépassé le cadre de l'affaire qui devait
inscrire pour simplement faire du
militantisme politique alors on va
préciser à la référence au mur des cons
murs des cons à c’était un panneau
affiché dans les locaux du Syndicat de
la magistrature et qui dénigrer
certaines personnalité et ça avait fait
polémique à l'époque en 2013 Philippe
dominatti a quasiment 20 ans après votre
entrée au Sénat quel temps fort vous
vous retenez de vos mandats
alors j'étais très motivé parce que je
suis
libéral sur le plan économique c'est
pour ça que bon ça m'a amusé vous fait
sourire que vous dites que je suis
Sarkozy je suis pas Sarkozy je suis un
libéral et j'essaie de trouver dans la
droite et jeunes politiques qui essayent
d'appliquer au mieux la concurrence pour
libérer notre économie avec moins
d'étapesibles et être comme les pays
développés de nos concurrents je dirais
au moins européen voilà ça c'était ma
ligne de conduite deuxièmement je suis
pour la construction européenne donc
vous voyez qu'effectivement je me trouve
pas nécessairement à l'aise dans ce
qu'on incarne aujourd'hui la droite
sénatoriale et les temps forts c'est mon
regret de ne pas avoir pu sensibiliser
suffisamment sur les sujets économiques
le budget de l'État et notamment le
déficit et la dette je me suis dès le
premier jour et c'est pour cela que j'ai
été je dirais
orienté vers la commission des finances
je me souviens de Philippe Marini qui
parlait de la soutenabilité de la dette
lorsque je suis rentré dans cette maison
elle était évidemment inférieure à 60%
du PIB on la multiplié par deux dans cet
espace c'est un sujet qu'on évoque plus
beaucoup mais qui m'inquiète qui
inquiète je dirais tout le responsable
politique parce qu'un jour ou l'autre il
va falloir passer je dirais à l'action
ce qu'on ne fait absolument pas le
président de la République qui a été
ministre des Finances je vous le
rappelle c'est pas depuis six ans c'est
depuis 11 ans que ce sujet géré par les
mêmes hommes et que à chaque fois on
nous dit vous verrez demain ça ira mieux
donc ça c'est effectivement un regret
sur la durée deuxième bon j'ai participé
à la non privétisation d'ADP alors que
je suis un libéral et je dirais par les
parlementaires comme moi de la majorité
sénatoriale qu'on en a empêché la
privatisation d'ADP pourquoi parce que
c'était un dossier scandaleux et je suis
content d'avoir participé à cela alors
que je suis favorable d'une manière
générale à ce type d'orientation
dernière question d'Alex peut-être
est-ce qu'il y a une loi un débat qui
vous a marqué pendant ces mandats
non pas particulièrement parce que je
pense que le on a eu deux crises pendant
un crise financière alors crise du
terrorisme le Christ sanitaire si vous
voulez même trois crises malheureusement
on est dans une société où on a une
crise presque par décennie en
l'occurrence c'est même faux puisque
c'est plus court 3 en 20 ans
et à chaque fois on justifie des mesures
exceptionnelles qui sont des mesures à
cause de la crise et en réalité c'est
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à résoudre les
problèmes du pays de la société c'est ça
qui me marque on n'a pas réussi pendant
ce délai alors qu'on a annoncé à
plusieurs reprises qu'il fallait réduire
le périmètre de l'État être plus inconnu
on n'a pas réussi à le faire non
seulement le périmètre de l'État n'a pas
été réduit mais celui des collectivités
territoriales a grossi également on est
l'un des seuls pays où on juxtapose
beaucoup d'élus locaux on les
déresponsabilis et puis à côté on a une
administration jacobine qui date d'il y
a deux siècles avec
cette organisation pyramidale de l'État
ou effectivement on doit avoir des
préfets qui vont contester le pouvoir
des mers par exemple et merci philippe
Dominati on va remercier Alex à tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure on parlera on
reparlera évidemment de ses émeutes
merci Philippe d'avoir été avec nous on
a bien compris que si vous quittez le
Sénat vous n'abandonnez pas la politique
pour les municipales
on aura l'occasion de vous entendre
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
dans 20 minutes dans le club
elle de cette nuit a été précaire débat
entre le porte-parole de renaissance le
Seigneur et l'éditorialiste Catherine
tricot parle tout de suite de ses
émeutes avec lui carbonas qui nous
rejoint